i
[Música]
el tenista serbio novak djokovic
permanecerá en un hotel bajo supervisión
de las autoridades migratorias hasta el
lunes cuando la justicia australiana
analizará el caso luego de que se le
impidiera ingresar por no poder
demostrar que la exención médica que
obtuvo para participar en el abierto de
australia es genuina serbia asegura que
el deportista está siendo discriminado
rusia y sus aliados de la organización
del tratado de seguridad colectiva
iniciaron el despliegue de tropas en
kazajistán para controlar los disturbios
decenas de personas perdieron la vida a
manos de las fuerzas de seguridad en
medio de las protestas en rechazo al
aumento del precio del combustible
se cumple un año desde que seguidores
del ex presidente de donald trump
tomaron el capitolio de eeuu el fiscal
general eric harland reiteró que todos
los responsables ya sean materiales o
intelectuales serán llevados ante la
justicia
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos este informativo en australia
un tribunal analizará el lunes el caso
del tenista serbio novak djokovic a
quien se le revocó el visado con el que
ingresó al país tras no poder comprobar
que la extensión médica presentada es
genuina la corte indicó que ambas partes
deberán entregar las respectivas
evidencias para determinar si el número
1 del tenis mundial podrá participar en
el abierto de australia donde defendería
subtítulo serbia aseguró que djokovic
está siendo víctima de discriminación el
primer ministro australiano scott
morrison lo desmintió
ningún individuo no se trata de ningún
individuo en particular es simplemente
una cuestión de seguir las reglas y por
lo tanto esos procesos seguirán su curso
durante las próximas horas adenex y
wells en ese evento se desarrollará como
debe ser
la organización mundial de la salud
reveló que en las últimas 24 horas se
reportaron más de 22 millones de nuevos
contagios de koi 19 algo que está
directamente relacionado con el avance
de la variante omicron la veloz
expansión de este linaje y los síntomas
aparentemente menos severos han llevado
a expertos mundiales a indicar que
podría acercarnos al final de la
pandemia uno de ellos es el doctor
adolfo garcía sastre director del
instituto de salud global y patógenos
emergentes de la escuela hay camp de
medicina del hospital mount sinaí en
nueva york bienvenido a france 24 ya hay
datos suficientes y evidencias
científicas sobre los síntomas menos
graves de omikron
bueno está claro que causa menos
enfermedades pero el problema es que
como hay muchos más casos debido a su
gran capacidad de transmisión los casos
enfermedad severa absolutos pueden
llegar a ser muy parecidos a los que
había antes pero desde luego la
proporción de enfermedad severa que
causa un micrón es mucho menor que la
que causaban las variantes anteriores
bueno y además de lo anterior a qué
factores se debe que consideren que
consideren esta variante como algo
beneficioso para repartir inmunidad
entre la población
sí bueno estamos viendo que el virus
está cambiando como nos esperábamos
desde el punto de vista evolutivo y que
es el modo en que está cambiando es el
modo de que normalmente acaban las
pandemias las pandemias anteriores es
decir el virus se vuelve más
transmisible es capaz de infectar alguna
gran cantidad de gente las personas
adquieren inmunidad debido a esta
infección y eso da lugar también a una
disminución todavía más de la de la
capacidad de producir enfermedad lo
diferente con respecto antes pandemias
sobre todo pandemias de hace ya 50 años
es que esta vez hemos tenido una vacuna
que ha logrado disminuir el número de
muertes que podía haber causado el virus
pero seguramente un micro 11 ya la
última parte que tenemos la pandemia y
una vez que pase omicron el virus se
quedará con nosotros pero ya no causará
tantos casos tantos números de casos y
eso dará lugar a que se vuelva un virus
normal como otros virus respiratorios y
a321 y con el pasar del tiempo empezamos
a escuchar un cambio en la terminología
de pandemia a endemia porque hoy 19 qué
significa esta nueva consideración
bueno pandemia es algo que es un
acontecimiento global infeccioso que
involucra a todo el mundo y que da lugar
a una emergencia mientras que endemias
cuando el virus existe en
circulando a un nivel relativamente bajo
pero presente en distintos sitios y
luego epidemia que es la otra que es la
otra acepción que seguramente también
nos quede el virus no sólo como endémico
es decir en distintos casos pero muy
poquitos por distintas zonas pero cómo
epidémico quiere decir que eso causará
un poco más número de casos durante las
epidemias que seguramente sean
estacionales de invierno igual que
ocurre con las epidemias de gripe o con
otras epidemias otros virus
respiratorios que suelen ser dura un
pico en invierno y por eso se llaman
epidemias por un pico que da que dar
lugar pero es un pico mucho menor que el
que dan los picos pandémicos a los que
estamos expuestos ahora bueno hace sólo
unos días científicos franceses
indicaron que identificaron una nueva
variante con 46 mutaciones frente a la
original y los expertos alertan que
seguirán presentándose si la gente no se
vacuna cómo funciona este proceso de
adaptación y cómo lo frenan las y no
acciones
si el virus siempre está montando y el
número de mutaciones que es que se
presenta en el mundo depende también de
la cantidad de virus que haya cuanto más
virus haya más espectro mutacional es
decir si por ejemplo 0 1 por ciento de
los virus que hay en el mundo tiene una
mutación pues si hay a billones o
trillones de virus en el mundo pues las
mutaciones que existen presentes son
mayores y eso da lugar a una mayor
variabilidad genética que hace que el
virus favorezca que pueda cambiar
adaptarse más rápidamente e incluso
poder poder evadir inmunidad
preexistente por vacuna por vacunación
es decir cuanto menos circulando haya
menos variantes va a haber que den lugar
a problemas eso no quiere decir que
desaparezcan completamente pero si
desaparecen la velocidad en que en la
que llegan así como el tiempo en que
llegan pueden aparecer variantes en
lugar de cada cuatro meses que es lo que
estamos viendo ahora mismo con este
virus pues pueden aparecer a lo mejor
cada dos años doctor garcía sastre a
usted muchísimas gracias por su análisis
y por compartirlo con nosotros en france
vamos a kazajistán donde rusia y la
alianza de las naciones ex soviéticas
iniciaron el despliegue de tropas para
controlar las protestas en contra del
aumento de los precios del gas licuado
que es usado como combustible por los
ciudadanos decenas de manifestantes han
muerto a manos de la policía y el
ejército y cientos más han resultado
heridos el presidente aceptó la dimisión
del gobierno y echó marcha atrás al
aumento de las tarifas pero las
manifestaciones continúan
en otras noticias se cumple un año de la
toma al capitolio de eeuu que ocurrió el
6 de enero de 2021 seguidores del
entonces presidente de donald trump
asaltaron la sede del congreso para
impedir que los legisladores
certificarán la victoria de joe biden en
las presidenciales de noviembre de 2020
un procedimiento tradicionalmente sin
mucha importancia que ese día fue muy
relevante gabriel coll chen nos hace un
repaso de lo que sucedió
cerca de dos meses después de las
elecciones presidenciales de noviembre
de 2020 donald trump todavía no
reconocía su derrota y llamó a sus
seguidores a las calles de cara a la
jornada de votación en el congreso para
certificar la victoria de joe biden como
presidente enormes protestas en
washington 10 y el 6 de enero vengan
será salvaje miles de manifestantes se
desplegaron en washington dc y caminaron
hacia el capitolio mientras donald trump
los alentaba
todos los que estamos aquí hoy no
queremos ver nuestra victoria electoral
robada por demócratas de izquierda
radical envalentonados por los medios de
comunicación de noticias falsas eso es
lo que han hecho y lo que están haciendo
nunca nos rendiremos nunca consideremos
la victoria eso no sucederá no sucede
cuando hay un robo de por medio
poco después los manifestantes lleguen
al capitolio e invaden sus escalones
hasta entrar al recinto adentro la
acción se suspende y la policía evacúa a
los legisladores varios representantes
como el list even se esconden en sus
oficinas estoy refugiado en mi oficina
el edificio al lado fue evacuado no
puedo creer que tengo que escribir eso
mientras tanto se alzan las voces para
pedirle a donald trump que exija el fin
del asalto tras varias horas de silencio
el ex presidente finalmente se expresa
en su cuenta de twitter y pide a los
manifestantes a regresar a casa aún sin
reconocer la derrota
'la acción' estas fueron unas elecciones
fraudulentas pero no podemos hacerle el
juego a esta gente tenemos que tener paz
así que váyanse a casa socorro
cerca de 800 seguidores de donald trump
han sido procesados mientras que un
comité del senado investiga quién estuvo
detrás del ataque y especialmente el
papel de donald trump y el tradicional
desfile de los reyes magos' regresó a
las calles de madrid pese al aumento de
casos de kobe 19 pero este año se
celebraron en todo el país con
restricciones debido al incremento de
los contagios sólo 7000 personas
pudieron asistir al evento y se prohibió
lanzar dulces la parte más tradicional
de la celebración esta fecha es esperada
por los niños en españa donde los
regalos se entregan el 6 de enero
llegamos al final del informativo los
invitamos a visitar nuestra página web
france24 puntocom para ampliar todo el
contenido y repetir este y otros
programas gracias por su sintonía
quédense con nosotros que volvemos en
breve aquí en france 24
[Música]